ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 35
Beratung des Antrags der Fraktionen die
Linke mit dem Titel
energiesoli für Spitzen verdienenende
Vorschlag der Wirtschaftsweisen umsetzen
für die Aussprache ist eine Dauer von 39
Minuten vereinbart
ich bitte zügig die Plätze zu wechseln
also dieser Wechsel absolut notwendig
weil andere Fachpolitiker jetzt nachdem
ihr gerade die Gesundheitspolitiker
waren jetzt noch einmal beraten da geht
es noch mal mehr um Finanz- und
Haushaltsfragen bei diesem Antrag
vielleicht noch ein interessanterie zu
diesem Entschließungsantrag der Union
der Bundestag hatte gestern auch noch
mal hier debattiert es geht unter
anderem in diesem Antrag auch um Fragen
von Erbschaftssteuer und
Grunderwerbsteuer beim Vererben von
Vermögen insbesondere von
Immobilienvermögen dass es etwas womit
sich die Union hier nicht durchsetzen
konnte zum Energie so die jetzt
Christian Görke ihr Sprecher für
Finanzpolitik der Linken war mein
Finanzminister in Brandenburg 27 Februar
ein Tag hier im Bundestag der
Bundeskanzler hatte hier die Zeitenwende
ausgerufen aus dieser Zeitenwende folgte
unter anderem natürlich auch eine
fragwürdige Aufrüstung aber auch eine
von uns begrüßte zaghafte Aufweichung
der Schuldenbremse wo ist aber gar keine
Zeiten zeitenwände gab und gibt ist in
einer gerechten Steuerpolitik in dieser
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und da liegt
die Richtlinienkompetenz allem
anscheinend bei Christian Lindner und
dementsprechend wurde ja auch mit dem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz die
Steuererleichterung vor allen Dingen bei
gut und besser bei verdienenden verortet
das ist wahr angesichts der sozialen
Verwerfungen in diesem Land in der
größten Krise die wir erleben nicht zu
erklären
während hier die Ampel meine Damen und
Herren
steuerpolitisch auf Durchzug stellt gab
es aber eine steuerpolitische
zeitenwände woanders und wenn wir schon
bei der Begriff Revolution sind heute
dann kann man das schon als revolutionär
bezeichnen die gab es eben bei den
Wirtschaftsweisen und ehrlich gesagt das
hat mich schon überrascht und für alle
Zuschauerinnen Zuschauer an den
Bildschirm und den Gästen hier im Saal
seit kurz erklärt bei den
Wirtschaftsweisen handelt sich um einen
Sachverständigenrat der Bundesregierung
also ihr Sachverständigenrat meine Damen
und Herren von der Bundesregierung die
sie berufen haben und nicht irgendwie
eine Vorfeldorganisation der Linken
diese Wirtschaftsweisen meine Damen und
Herren Künstler das hat wirklich mich
wirklich beeindruckt schlägt vor
um in der Krise hier solidarisch
bewältigen zu können dass es derzeit
keine keine Steuerentlastung und für
Reiche und Vermögen in diesem Land geben
soll und
zeitlich befristet ein sogenannter
energiesoli eingeführt werden soll nun
haben sie meine Damen und Herren von SPD
grün und FDP im Rahmen der
Spitzenverdiener entlassungsgesetz ja
schon mal beschlossen diese
gutverdienenden überproportional zu
entlassen und deshalb wird ja wenigstens
dann die zweite Forderung der
Wirtschaftsweisen eine Energie Soli
einzuführen doch umso wichtiger und dem
wir heute auch mit unserem Antrag
einfordern und deshalb noch einmal zur
Klarstellung der überhaupt hier diesen
Energie so die zahlen müsste wenn man
ihn so ausgestalten würde wie den Soli
dann würden zum Beispiel
single-einkommen beginnt ab 80.000 €
brutto 80.000 € brutto betroffen und im
Land Brandenburg während es zum Beispiel
die jetzt in die Zahlen 75.000 Personen
von
1,22 Millionen Steuerpflichtigen nur mal
diese Zahlen also ein überschaubarer
Zahlung auf ganz Deutschland berechnet
wurden also nur die oberen zehn Prozent
der gutverdienenden hier bedacht eben
die dax-manager mit den Bonis natürlich
aber auch ampelministerinnen und
ampelminister würden hier mal zur Kasse
gebeten meine Damen und Herren und vor
allen Dingen hätten wir Einnahmen von ca
10 Milliarden Euro ich komme zum Schluss
von Präsidentin angesichts dieser
größten Krise mit schuldenfinanzierten
Rettungspaketen in nie da gewesener Höhe
sind wir schon dafür ein zeitlich
befristeten so die einzuführen und da
freue ich mich schon auf die Debatte
jetzt danke
[Applaus]
für die SPD-Fraktion hat jetzt der
Kollege Zorn das Wort
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren Herr Gürtel lieber
Christian ich muss sagen ich bin
enttäuscht
weil sie sich mehr und mehr hier
demaskieren es wird mehr und mehr hier
deutlich dass es Ihnen gar nicht um
konstruktive Oppositionsarbeit geht
sondern eine Woche nacheinander holen
sie irgendein anderen Partei
Parteitagsbeschluss der SPD raus oder
das was die Wirtschaftsweisen gesagt
haben das Holen Sie hier raus und
bringen sie und bringen Sie hier als
Antrag und es geht ihm gar nicht darum
inhaltlich darüber zu diskutieren
sondern es geht in viel mehr darum zu
zeigen dass es innerhalb der Ampel
zwischen SPD und Grüne und FDP
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen gibt und
das finde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht ins
Ziel den wir uns angewöhnen soll ich
schätze sie sehr aber so können wir
nicht weiter Politik machen so können
wir nicht in diesen Zeiten wo die
Menschen viel mehr von uns erwarten als
nur diese symbolische Anträge das kann
nicht unser Politik Ziel sein
aber lieber Görke ich will auch
inhaltlich zu dem Antrag reden es ist ja
nicht so dass sie uns der Debatte nicht
stellen und dass wir dem gegenüber sehr
offen sind das wissen Sie ja wir haben
uns sie ist bezüglich geäußert und wir
sind tatsächlich der Meinung dass ein
Energie Soli jetzt in der Krise eine von
vielen verschiedenen Maßnahmen wäre die
dafür sorgen können dass wir bei den
entlastungspakete mehr Zielgenauigkeit
erzielen denn wenn Sie diesen Antrag
oder wenn Sie den Jahresbericht der
Wirtschaftsweisen gelesen haben dann
haben sie festgestellt dass viele der
verschiedenen Entlastungsmaßnahmen die
wir auf den Weg gebracht haben gelobt
wurden dass wir es uns gelungen sind auf
der Angebotsseite die Angebote zu
erweitern und dafür zu sorgen dass wir
temporär für mehr Energie sorgen können
das ist gut aber dass sie auf der
Nachfrage Seite auch massiv Geld in die
Hand übernommen hat genommen haben und
Menschen zu unterstützen ist etwas was
die Wirtschaftsweisen für gut halten
aber eine Kritik eine Kritik müssen wir
uns gefallen lassen das liegt aber viel
damit zusammen dass wir kaum Maßnahmen
haben um direkt Transfers zu tätigen das
ist etwas was wir schmerzhaft gelernt
haben dass wir festgestellt haben woran
auch das Wirtschaftsministerium mit
Hochdruck daran arbeitet damit wir
zukünftig viel zielgenauer sein können
bei den verschiedenen entlastungspakete
die vielleicht noch kommen werden aber
Herr Görke ich will auch noch mal eins
sagen
unsere Partei meine Fraktion unsere
Fraktion wenn es um diese Themen geht
wenn es um mehr Steuergerechtigkeit wenn
es mehr gesellschaftliche und soziale
Gerechtigkeit geht da können Sie immer
mit uns als Partner rechnen aber aber
was aber nicht geht was aber nicht geht
ist Woche für Woche ein Antrag nach dem
anderen hier zu bringen
Woche ein Antrag nach dem anderen hier
zu bringen und und viel mehr und viel
mehr uns dafür kritisieren dass wir da
in der Sache bei ihnen sind aber die
sich zustimmen können das ist nicht
unsere Vorstellung von Politik und liebe
FDP und das ist vielleicht das was uns
auch unterscheidet wir haben zwar
unterschiedliche Meinungen wenn es
beispielsweise in der Steuerpolitik
darum geht wen wir jetzt in diesen
Zeiten entlassen müssen aber was wir tun
ist wir diskutieren haben und der Sache
und am Ende finden wir eine Lösung womit
das ganze Land leben kann und das ist
das was auch diese Ampelkoalition
auszeichnet
ich will aber noch zwei drei Sätze sagen
warum ich das grundsätzlich auch gut
finde einmal haben wir jetzt in der
Situation damit zu tun dass wir nicht
nur die Krise bewältigen müssen und das
wollen wir solidarisch machen deswegen
haben wir auch die verschiedenen
entlassungspakete auf dem Weg gebracht
aber zeitgleich wollen wir auch in die
Transformation investieren und auch das
kostet viel Geld wir haben das hier in
den letzten Haushalt damit gemacht dass
wir viel mehr Schulden aufgenommen haben
das ist richtig Schulden sind per se
schlecht oder gut es kommt stets drauf
an wofür sie verwendet werden was ich
aber Glaube und Liebe FDP das ist auch
mein Appell an ihn was sich nicht
empfiehlt ist es Schulden aufzunehmen um
viel mehr unverteilung zu sorgen das
empfiehlt sich nicht wenn es darum geht
viel mehr Solidarität zu sorgen wenn es
darum geht insbesondere diejenigen zu
unterstützen die jetzt in diesen Zeiten
am stärksten davon getroffen sind
sollten wir steuerpolitisch was machen
und wir haben mit der Erbschaftsteuer
wir haben in der einmaligen
Vermögensabgabe wir haben aber auch mit
den Energie Soli eine Möglichkeit dies
zu tun oder würde auch dafür sorgen dass
wir mehr Gerechtigkeit schaffen deswegen
deswegen freue ich mich da auch auf die
weiteren Diskussion und auch nochmal auf
das Argument von Frauen aufzugreifen
dass wir mehr Zielgenauigkeit haben wir
haben es doch erlebt und das kann
sicherlich fast jeder Abgeordnete aus
diesem Hause bezeugen das viele Menschen
auf uns zugekommen sind haben gesagt ich
verdiene schon so viel Geld dass ich gar
kein energiezuschlag mehr brauche ich
verdiene schon so viel Geld dass ich
nicht verstehe warum ich von den
Maßnahmen profitiere nun können wir das
nicht kurzfristig lösen weil wir das
nicht so Tage im spezifisch machen
können was wir aber machen können ist es
nämlich mit ein Energie so lieber
beispielsweise dafür zu sorgen dass
insbesondere diejenigen die jetzt am
meisten Geld haben und jetzt noch
zusätzlich unterstützt werden weil wir
entsprechend nicht diese direkttransfers
machen können doch ein Beitrag dafür
leisten können und das würde viel mehr
Ausgleich sorgen deswegen begrüßen wir
diese Maßnahme liebe Kollegen Kollegen
die erleben den Antrag der Fraktion DIE
LINKE ab soll aber nicht inhaltlich sein
sondern es geht um die Art und Weise wie
wir miteinander hier Politik machen
wollen
nein nein es geht darum es geht darum es
geht darum und das gehört und da will
ich doch mal da will ich doch mal einen
Satz dazu sagen weil in der
Bundesrepublik ist es nun mal so dass
wir ein System haben wo verschiedene
Parteien Wahlkampf machen basierend auf
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen und am
Ende gibt es ein Ergebnis und dann
müssen Parteien zusammenkommen und
gemeinsam Ring und am Ende passieren auf
den Koalitionsvertrag vereinbaren wie
sie für die nächsten vier Jahre regieren
wollen was natürlich die was natürlich
nicht geht ist es dann eigenständig zu
entscheiden dass man eine Entscheidung
anders treffen möchte nur weil man das
selbst gut findet für die Stabilität des
Landes insbesondere Krisenzeiten ist es
sehr sehr wichtig dass die Koalition hat
diskutiert aber in der Sache dafür sorgt
dass das Land regierungsfähig bleibt und
insbesondere diesen Krisenzeiten ist es
wichtiger mehr denn geht vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort hat der Kollege Olaf guting für
die cdu/csu-fraktion
ja frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen nicht nur die Ampel kann
Steuern erhöhen und neue Steuern
einführen nein auch die Linke beglückt
uns heute mit einem wieder neuen Antrag
zur Umverteilung gefühlt werden sie ja
dabei der Linken immer so in der
Vorweihnachtszeit besonders kreativ ich
erinnere mich noch gut an 2018 ihren
Antrag zur Einführung eines
weihnachtskindergeldes und mit dem
aktuellen Antrag den wir heute zum
energie-soli haben da knüpfen sie
nahtlos an den Unsinn der letzten Jahre
an
es ist suggerieren hier mit ihrem Antrag
das gut verdienende bei den
energieentlastungspaketen der Regierung
mehr Entlastung erhielten als Personen
mit kleinen Einkommen das stimmt aber
schon gar nicht dass die Entlastungen
der dezemberhilfe und die gaspreisbremse
einigermaßen sozial ausgewogen sind
dafür hat die Bundesregierung dann
tatsächlich gesorgt allerdings darauf
muss man Hinweisen mit einem Missbrauch
des Steuerrechts mit großer rechts und
Sicherheit mit einem wahnsinnigen
Bürokratieaufwand mit erheblichen
zusätzlichen Belastungen für Bürger
Stadtwerke Unternehmen und daraus
entstehen natürlich wieder neue
Ungerechtigkeiten aber das ist an dieser
Stelle tatsächlich eine andere
Geschichte
in ihrem Antrag machen Sie sich eine
Aussage aus dem Jahresgutachten das
sogenannten Wirtschaftsweisen zu eigen
die Einführung eines zeitlich
befristeten
energiesolidaritätszuschlages der so
lange gelten könnte wie die
gaspreisbremse greift natürlich blenden
Sie bei diesem herauspicken dieser
Rosine alle anderen Aussagen der
Sachverständigen aus das passt natürlich
nicht ins Konzept deswegen blicken sie
nur auf diesen einen Teil und nachdem
sie ja in der Vergangenheit schon immer
wieder Anträge gestellt haben zur
Vermögensabgabe zur
Vermögenssteuer einmal für Millionäre
dann für Milliardäre der Kollege
Christian von Städten hat man
nachgezählt in den letzten Jahren haben
sie diesen Antrag schon 20 mal gestellt
und sind jedes Mal gescheitert jetzt
finden Sie neuen Grund den Bürgern in
die Tasche zu greifen und der heißt
jetzt Energie Soli da über 90 Prozent
der Bevölkerung unter einer CDU
geführten Bundesregierung von der
Zahlung des Solidaritätszuschlages
entlastet wurde stürzt man sich jetzt
bei der Linken auf den kleinen
verbliebenen Teil der noch
Solidaritätszuschlag bezahlt und will
denen zusätzlich auch noch mal einen
energiesoli obendrauf setzen es sind die
oberen zehn Prozent der
einkommensteuerzahler die jetzt schon
95% des Solidaritätszuschlages zahlen
und über die Hälfte des gesamtaufkommens
bei der Einkommensteuer beitragen und
das sind nicht nur die Dax Manager und
die Minister die sie an ihrem vorherigen
Antrag oben in der
Headline hatten
die Fußballer hätten sie dann noch
vergessen die hätten es jetzt vielleicht
auch verdient nach dem Spiel gestern
sondern das sind tatsächlich
selbstständige Handwerker kleine
Unternehmer Menschen die hart für ihr
Einkommen arbeiten und die an den Folgen
des Angriffskrieges von Russland auf die
Ukraine an der an den Folgen der
steigenden Energiepreise an der
Inflation genauso leiden wie alle
anderen auch nun ist es ein Heeres Ziel
dass wir den Staat auch immer wieder auf
der Einnahmenseite
stärken dass wir gegen Finanzierungen
finden aber und diesen Teil des
Wirtschafts des Gutachtens der
Wirtschaftsweisen den lassen sie weg
dieser Vorschläge wie zum Beispiel ein
Energie Soli die führen zu zusätzlichen
Belastungen bei Haushalten und
Unternehmen und die und das sagen auch
die Wirtschaftsweisen die wegen sich
wach stoßdämpfend aus und jeder
vernünftige Ökonom würde doch in einer
Situation wo wir eine wirtschaftlich
unsichere Zeit haben alles vermeiden um
zusätzliche Belastungen zu bekommen wir
müssen alles tun damit wir Arbeitsplätze
am Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
erhalten können
Steuererhöhungen gehören da ganz sicher
nicht dazu deswegen ab in die
Mottenkiste mit dem solidaritäts-
[Applaus]
für die Fraktionen Bündnis 90 die Grünen
spricht nun der Kollege Sascha Müller
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hat sich den Tagesordnungspunkt gesehen
habe der zunächst als energiesoli DAX
Manager und Minister zur Kasse
aufgesetzt war habe ich erstmal einen
Schreck bekommen wie populistisch ist
das denn bitte jetzt bin ich zumindest
beruhigt darüber dass der Antrag am Ende
relativ rhetorisch moderat Energie Soli
fürs Spitzen verdiente Vorschlag der
Wirtschaftsweisen umsetzen überschrieben
ist der Antrag selber ist ja auch recht
kurz gehalten sie wollen die
Bundesregierung auffordern ein
Gesetzentwurf vorzulegen der einen neuen
Energie wurde die realitätszuschlag
gemäß Artikel 106 Absatz 1,6 das
Grundgesetzes vorsieht und sich am
Vorbild des derzeitigen
Solidaritätszuschlag ist für die oberen
zehn Prozent orientieren soll nun
erinnern wir uns erinnern wer uns mal an
das Inflationsausgleich Gesetz über das
wir hier das ist ja bekannt lange mühsam
gerungen haben über eines waren wir uns
in der Koalition bei diesem Gesetz immer
einig dass die Eckwerte im
Einkommensteuertarif bei der sogenannten
gleichen Steuer diesmal nicht angepasst
werden und damit um in der Logik der
Befürworter des Ausweis der kalten
Progression zu bleiben für diesen
Personenkreis eine reale Steuerung haben
wir dann hingenommen es ließe sich also
argumentieren dass wir das Kernanliegen
dieses Antrags eigentlich in stückweit
schon erfüllt haben aber sie merken
schon
dass wir dem Antrag nicht folgen werden
aber mit dem Hinweis auf den neuesten
Bericht des Sachverständigenrates zur
Begutachtung der gesamtwirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung haben sie natürlich einen
wichtigen Punkt und die Frage danach ob
den starken Schultern in der Krise mehr
zuzumuten wäre und wenn ja vor allem wie
das geschehen sollte dies natürlich
berechtigt
unser vordringliches Ziel als Ampel ist
es natürlich zunächst dass Menschen und
Unternehmen gut durch den Winter kommen
und ich bin mittlerweile optimistisch
dass uns das gelingt vor allem besser
gelingen wird als so manche auch hier
gehofft und schon von einem Protest
heißen protestherbst geträumt haben der
ja dann ausgeblieben ist hier zeigt sich
unsere tatkräftige Regierung diese
fortschrittskoalition gehört zu den
Machern zu den mutmachern andere hier
verlegen sich dagegen ausschließlich auf
das mies machen wünschen sich so ist
sogar ist aus Video ja dokumentiert aus
parteipolitischen Motiven ein Scheitern
und das alles den Bach runter geht das
wird aber nicht passieren und das hier
ganz rechts und leider muss ich sagen
auch in Teilen auf der anderen Seite die
Hauses dieses übliche Spiel gespielt
wird ist das eine und nicht anders zu
erwarten dass aber vor den Vorsitzenden
von CDU und CSU im Sommer immer wieder
von einem Blackout in diesem Winter wir
gehört haben dass diese einzigste
geschürt haben auch das war nicht
hilfreich unsere gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt in dieser so schwierigen
Zeit
was machen wir aber nun behandeln wir
schützen die Menschen und die
Unternehmen wir lassen die Menschen
nicht alleine und wir machen mal das
pragmatisch aber entschlossen schon die
Ankündigung der Strom- und
gaspreisbremsen hat zu einer Beruhigung
der Märkte geführt jetzt geht es hier im
parlamentarischen Verfahren um die
Details und natürlich kommt es bei hier
bei einem so starken markteingriff den
wir selber von nicht allzu langer Zeit
so gar nicht uns vorstellen konnten sehr
auf Gründlichkeit an bei alldem müssen
wir natürlich darauf achten dass es
gerecht zugeht darauf haben wir bei
unseren Entlastungsmaßnahmen geachtet
ich könnte jetzt den Rest meiner
Redezeit damit fühlen die Maßnahmen
mehrerer milliardenschwere
entlastungspakete erneut alle
aufzuzählen aber ich beschränke mich
darauf denn wir reden ja von den starken
Schultern darauf hinzuweisen dass wir
vorhin mit dem Jahressteuergesetz wenige
Minuten erst her den Energiekreis
krisenbeitrag beschlossen haben Zufalls
Gewinne von Energiekonzernen können wir
nun zu 35 Prozent abschöpfen damit
können wir den Bundeshaushalt bis zu dem
Bundesrat aus bis zu drei Milliarden
Euro zurückgeführt werden und wir
beteiligen krisengewinne an der
Finanzierung der umfassenden
entlastungspakete der letzten Monate
damit große Konzerne hier nicht einfach
die Besteuerung umgehen können haben wir
uns im parlamentarischen Verfahren für
nachschärfungen eingesetzt und ja
[Applaus]
wenn dieses Land auch dank unserer
Regierung durch die Energiekrise und die
damit verbundene Inflation gekommen ist
wird sicherlich die Frage auftauchen ob
es weitere Krisengewinner gibt die die
vielleicht auch einen erhöhten Beitrag
leisten können und die
vermögensungleichheit in Deutschland
gerade über europäischen Vergleich die
besteht weiterhin gesellschaftliche und
politische Diskussion darüber sind
legitim und wir brauchen diese Debatten
im Moment liegt das Hauptaugenmerk der
Regierung aber auf der Krisen
Bewältigung und angesichts der Vielzahl
der Herausforderung haben wir gut zu tun
daran arbeiten wir gemeinsam als
ampelparteien und das sehr erfolgreich
die Menschen in Deutschland können sich
glücklich schätzen dass sie sich
angesichts dieser herausfordernden
Zeiten im letzten Jahr für diese
Koalition entschieden haben für diese
fortschrittskoalition die einerseits die
Krisen gut managed und andererseits
gleichzeitig die richtigen
Weichenstellungen für die Zukunft stellt
danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank liest meine Damen und Herren
wir sind weiterhin in der Debatte rund
um den
energiesoli Sascha Müller war am Pult
von der Bündnis 90 grünen Fraktion und
als nächster Redner hat sich schon
bereit gemacht Jan Wenzel Schmidt von
der afd-fraktion Mitglied im
Finanzausschuss schon wieder haben die
Linken ihre immer gleichen Bücher
gewälzt das Ergebnis war natürlich das
gleiche wie sonst auch egal welches
Problem staatliche Umverteilung ist ihre
Lösung im heute vorliegenden Antrag
wollen die sed-nachfolger mit einem
energiesoli vermeintlich besser
verdienenende zur Kasse bitten die
Einführung des ursprünglichen
Solidaritätszuschlags weil jedoch damals
notwendig weil die ehemalige DDR durch
die Linke Wirtschaftspolitik
heruntergewirtschaftet wurde diese
wirtschaftsweisheit ist also das
wacklige Fundament Ihres Antrags sie
wollen mit ihrem Antrag das Blut des
Bürgers von Neid auch besser verdienende
zum Kochen bringen ihr perfide ziel ist
es so auf Wähler von zu gehen dabei
gehören nicht wenige linke auch zu den
Besserverdienern ein Blick in die Reihen
der Linken Schickeria ist
aufschlussreich ein
Fraktionsvorsitzender ihrer Fraktion
erhält monatlich rund 20.000 Euro und
ihre Fraktion gönnt sich mit dr Dietmar
Bartsch und Frau Amira Mohammed Ali
gleich zwei Vorsitzende die beide diesen
Antrag unterzeichnet haben 40.000 Euro
im Monat für zwei in effektive
frontfiguren
das entspricht im Übrigen na zu einem
durchschnittlichen Jahresgehalt in
Deutschland während der Wähler schuften
darf um die höheren Energiekosten zu
stemmen in Thüringen stellen die Linken
sogar die Ministerpräsidenten gerade da
sollten eigentlich linke
Spitzenpolitiker als Vorbild für
Bescheidenheit gelten jedoch hat zum
Beispiel ihr landtagskollege André
Blechschmidt ein paar nennenswerte
nehmen Einkünfte vorzuweisen neben
seiner Diät die ohnehin schon mit satten
7.745 Euro monatlich vergütet wird er
hält er für seine Anwesenheit in drei
Aufsichtsräten noch einmal
11.325 Euro es ist kein Einzelfall die
linke Abgeordnete Lena günger bessert
ihr Mandat mit einem Aufsichtsratsposten
und knapp 10.000 Euro auf auch in ihre
links politischen Stiftung quillt das
Steuergeld nur so aus jeder Fuge die
rosa luxemburg-stiftung wird jährlich
mit über 64 Millionen Euro gefördert
eine Aktivposten in ihrer Stiftung ist
Hermann Klenner er dürfte das das letzte
lebende ehemalige NSDAP-Mitglied sein
das in der Politik noch ein Amt
bekleidet ja dieser Herr hat den Weg von
der braunen Sozialistischen Partei in
die rote gefunden
währenddessen müssen immer mehr Familien
mit weniger auskommen weniger Geschenke
zu Weihnachten weniger Wärme zu Hause
weniger vollwertige Mahlzeiten wegen der
ideologischen selbstbeschneidung ihres
Horizontes geht ihr Antrag wieder
vollständig am Problem vorbei das
Problem sind die hohen Kosten für
Energie und Gas diese werden verursacht
von der katastrophalen Energie und
Sanktionspolitik der Ampelkoalition die
Lösung ist also ganz einfach nicht
Umverteilung sondern um sich die
Sanktionen müssen sofort beendet werden
gleichzeitig können wir uns von Russland
unabhängiger machen wenn wir in den
Neubau modernster Kernkraftwerke
investieren diese würden den Strom
unfassbar günstig machen so günstig dass
man damit sogar heizen könnte und für
die klimakleber auch noch CO2 neutral
Werte Kollegen wir benötigen keinen
energiesoli wie in die Linken fordern
wir brauchen maximal einen Soli für
linke Doppelmoral dann würde die
Staatskasse ordentlich gefüllt werden
wir lehnen ihren Antrag ab
[Applaus]
für eine kurze Intervention erhält jetzt
das Wort Gesine Lötsch
stimmt das wackelt ja jetzt vielen Dank
Frau Präsidentin mir geht es darum hier
Falschbehauptung richtig zu stellen
richtig ist dass wir zwei
Fraktionsvorsitzender haben aber sie
bekommen keine doppelten Diäten sondern
Anderthalbfache Diäten ein
parlamentarischer braucht der glaube ich
auch durch diese
verantwortungsvolle Tätigkeit
gerechtfertigt ist aber die
entscheidende Frage ist da das wird
alles voll versteuert und alle
steuererhöhungsvorschläge die wir machen
die auch zu unseren Lasten gehen würden
machen wir aus voller Überzeugung wir
sagen starke Schultern müssen mehr
tragen und wir brauchen
Steuergerechtigkeit in diesem Land
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
bin noch nicht jetzt so vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin danke auch für die
Kurzintervention ich helfe Ihnen gerne
noch mal beim Nachrichten also 10.000
Euro Grundentschädigung plus noch mal
die Hälfte hinzu macht 15.000 plus noch
mal die steuerfreie Kostenpauschale sind
im Monat rund 20.000 Euro Steuergeld sie
gönnen sich zwei Fraktionsvorsitzende
somit sind 40.000 € Steuergeld sie
sollten sich vielleicht mal am
Leistungsprinzip orientieren denn ihre
beinfraktionsvorsitzenden schaffen es ja
auch in den neuesten Umfragewerten sie
nicht wirklich über 5% zu bekommen wir
machen das wir halten uns ans
Leistungsprinzip und sind dabei sogar
noch steuerlich sehr effektiv unsere
Fraktionsvorsitzende haben uns wieder
15% in den Umfang eingebracht und wir
erhöhen trotzdem nicht die Zulagen
so das war noch ein kurzes Geplänkel
genannt kurz Intervention und
Reaktion darauf nach der Rede von Jan
Wenzel Schmidt hatte sich Gesine lötz
die Linke finanzpolitikerin zu Wort
gemeldet es geht weiter unter Debatte
und Maximilian Mordhorst ist mit
absoluter Dynamik zum Pult gegangen
FDP-Fraktion Finanzausschuss Mitglied
[Applaus]
einfach die Rede aus letzter Woche noch
mal Vortrage das ist aber passend auf
jeden Fall zu ihrem Antrag ich habe mich
dagegen entschieden weil sie sich ja
wirklich in diesem Fall konkret auf den
Sachverständigenrat äh beziehen und
sagen der Sachverständigenrat der Wolle
das jetzt was übrigens auch eine falsch
Darstellung ist er zieht es in Erwägung
an bestimmten Stellen und was sie auch
immer gerne machen als Linkspartei sie
blenden alles andere aus was der
Sachverständigenrat zu Recht fordert
oder unterstützt lassen Sie mich das
einmal vortragen der Sachverständigenrat
fordert das nicht zu viel Geld ins
System gegeben wird und freut sich dass
die Schuldenbremse im nächsten Jahr
wieder eingehalten wird ist das Politik
der Linkspartei ist das Politik die sie
unterstützen wollen nein es ist unsere
Politik es ist Politik die nachfolgende
Generation für Überschuldung schützt es
ist eine Politik die die die die der
Sachverständigenrat fordert in Bezug auf
den Spitzensteuersatz dieser solle
unbedingt später anfangen mittlerweile
zahlen 3, 8 Millionen Bürger
Spitzensteuersatz bei 1,4 beim
1,4-fachen des Durchschnittslohns fängt
der Spitzensteuersatz an wir haben mit
dem inflationsausgleichsgesetz dafür
gesorgt dass er später anfängt
insbesondere diesen inflationären Zeiten
ist das ein extrem wichtiges Signal für
die Mitte der Gesellschaft und der
Sachverständigenrat begrüßt die
aktienrente der Sachverständigenrat sagt
dass insbesondere durch linke Politik in
den letzten Jahrzehnten dafür gesorgt
wurde dass die Rente nicht zukunftsfähig
ist und dass viele Menschen gerade in
meiner Generation sich Sorgen sich große
Sorgen machen ob sie von der staatlichen
Rente überhaupt noch was haben deswegen
ist es genau richtig dass wir jetzt mit
der aktienrente einsteigen der
Sachverständigenrat fordert dass wir
dort sogar noch weiter gehen wir kommen
also wir kommen also dazu im kurzen sie
zitieren was Ihnen passt aber lassen die
anderen viel wichtigeren Dinge gerne aus
für uns ist klar gerade in diesen Zeiten
in denen insbesondere die Arbeiten in
der Mitte der Gesellschaft sehr leidet
und sich große Sorgen machen muss um die
Energieversorgung um die Wirtschaft auch
in Zukunft ist es das klare Signal der
Ampelkoalition einerseits keine
Steuererhöhung andererseits sogar haben
wir in diesem Jahr massive
Steuerentlastungen auf den Weg gebracht
das ist genau der richtige Weg und weil
ich eine Forderung beim Soli immer
wieder höre die aber sehr problematisch
ist in Bezug auf Vorsorge gerade kleiner
und mittlerer Einkommen der
Solidaritätszuschlag wird nämlich immer
noch auf Kapitalerträge gezahlt wir
haben jetzt den Sparer Pauschbetrag
erhöht das ist ein kleiner Schritt aber
wer über diesen Sparer Pauschbetrag
liegt das werden jetzt bei 1000 € im
Jahr sein der wird weiterhin
Solidaritätszuschlag sein arbeiten Sie
doch mal mit uns daran und da habe ich
von der Linkspartei noch nie etwas
gehört das kleine Einkommen wieder die
Möglichkeit haben Vermögen aufzubauen
dass diejenigen in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft Chancen darauf haben
vielleicht einmal ein Eigenheim zu
erwerben und es auch zu vererben
deswegen freue ich mich wenn die
Linkspartei mit uns daran arbeitet dass
gerade kleine und mittlere Einkommen
wieder Vermögen aufbauen können das ist
nicht viel größere soziale Verantwortung
die wir gemeinsam haben und ich würde
mich sehr freuen wenn die Linkspartei
uns da in Zukunft stärker unterstützt
insofern nicht mal neuer Wein in
weiterhin alten Schläuchen wir werden
Ihren Antrag ablehnen der
Koalitionsvertrag ist klar die
FDP-Fraktion ist klar mit uns wird es
keine Steuererhöhung in Deutschland
geben das ist gerade in diesen Zeiten
genau das richtige Signal vielen Dank
und das war sozusagen der Redebeitrag
von Max Mordhorst FDP Finanzausschuss
die Linksfraktion beantragt einen
Energie Soli für spitzenverdienende
aufzulegen und damit einen Vorschlag der
Wirtschaftsweisen aufzugreifen Sebastian
Brehm jetzt für die
unionsfraktionsprecher für Finanzen und
Haushalt der CSU Landesgruppe für
Spitzen verdienenende Vorschlag der
Wirtschaftsweisen umsetzen ich habe mich
schon ziemlich danach verzehrt Herr
lieber Herr Kollege Görke endlich mal
wieder eine Debatte über höhere Steuern
das hatten wir schon lange nicht mehr
letzte Woche Vermögensabgabe und
Lastenausgleich sie haben ja da fröhlich
mitgestimmt bei Rot und Grün und heute
morgen zumindest zugestimmt und heute
morgen eine drastische Erhöhung übrigens
Liebe Kollege Mordhorst wenn sie gerade
sagen die FDP macht es nicht heute
morgen eine drastische Erhöhung der
Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer durch die
Ampel mit Zustimmung der FDP übrigens
sie müssen bald aufpassen dass überhaupt
noch was da ist um um zu verteilen und
wegnehmen zu können
aber ich will fachlich auf den Antrag
eingehen erstens es ist
verfassungsrechtlich unzulässig eine
durch einen besonderen konkreten
Mittelbedarf des bundesbegründende
Ergänzungsabgabe zum allgemeinen Zweck
und zum sozialen Ausgleich zu
instrumentalisieren die ergänzungsgabe
Ergänzungsabgabe darf ihn ja sozialen
Verträglichkeit zwar fair ausgestaltet
sein aber der Grund für die Einführung
darf nicht ideologisch sein
sie haben das schlau gemacht ja muss ich
jetzt mal sagen Herr Kollege Görke weil
sie eben ihre Grundgedanken der
Umverteilung in den Antrag nicht direkt
reingetan haben sondern sie den Antrag
mit der Krise begründen und damit
sozusagen auf den Sachverständigenrat
eingehen
aber wenn man mal sieht wie der Antrag
ursprünglich war
energiesoli DAX Manager und Minister zur
Kasse dann sieht man natürlich den
wahren Hintergrund das ist der
umverteilungsgedanken der Linken das ist
ja auch ihr politischer Fußabdruck es
ist okay aber das natürlich da SPD und
Grüne grundsätzlich der Meinung sind
dass man auch mehr wegnehmen muss ist
schwierig also man sieht wer es Geistes
Kind ist ist aber ich will auf den
Gedanken der Wirtschaftsweisen
zurückkommen es war ja netter Versuch
das sozusagen da umzulenken
aber wenn man eine Ergänzungsabgabe
machen würde und dann müsste man
besondere und kostenintensive
Herausforderungen abfedern ohne neue
Schulden aufzunehmen das ist nämlich der
Hintergrund und wenn man sieht dass der
Bund bereits 540 Milliarden neue
Schulden aufgenommen hat diese Regierung
hat in einem Jahr mehr Schulden
aufgenommen als 16 Jahre Helmut Kohl und
16 Jahre Angela Merkel zusammen und das
übrigens zu Lasten der nächsten
Generation also wenn man eine über eine
Einführung eine Ergänzungsabgabe
nachdenkt dann darf es eben dann keine
neuen Schulden geben das hat die
Regierung anders gemacht und ich will
noch was sagen wenn sie von den oberen
zehn Prozent reden sondern fest für den
10%. das fängt an bei 3.400 Euro netto
und die als Millionäre und Milliardäre
und als Manager hinzustellen das ist die
ganz normale Familie mit zwei Einkommen
das ist der Handwerker das ist der
Mittelständler und wenn sie hier die Axt
Anlegen an diese mittleren Einkommen an
diese Betriebe dann werden sie
Arbeitsplätze vernichten und dann werden
sie bei den Facharbeitern auch dazu
führen dass sie nicht mehr arbeiten
wollen sondern vielleicht in das
Bürgergeld gehen sie nehmen die
Motivation der Menschen wenn sie hier in
die Tasche greifen war schon heute früh
genug mit dem Jahressteuergesetz 2022
und Liebe Kollege Mordhorst wenn Sie den
Spitzensteuersatz verschieben wollen
dann tun Sie es doch einfach sie sind ja
jetzt in der Regierung wir würden da
zustimmen der zweite Gedanken zur
Ergänzungsabgabe
in den einsteigigen
rechtswissenschaftlichen Gutachten und
in der Literatur ist ja die Frage noch
strittig ob überhaupt die
teilabschaffung des Solis
verfassungsgemäß ist hier läuft ja eine
Klage der FDP gegen jetzt des
fdp-finanzministerium ich bin gespannt
auf die Prozessführung aber es ist
insgesamt natürlich interessant wie
dieses ausgeht ich bin auch persönlich
der Meinung dass eine teilabschaffung
des Solidaritätszuschlags nicht geht und
dass der Solidaritätszuschlag gänzlich
abgeschafft werden muss aber warten wir
das Verfahren ab es gibt hier
unterschiedliche Urteile vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht vom
Bundesfinanzhof
Argumente dafür aber auch viele
Argumente dagegen insbesondere den
allgemeinen Gleichheitsgrundsatz nach
Artikel 3 Grundgesetz ich kann an dieser
Stelle nur sagen herzlichen Glückwunsch
wieder zum nächsten ideologischen Antrag
der Linken wir diskutieren gerne nächste
Woche wieder einen
interessante sind wir bloß eigentlich
die Reaktion der Ampel und wenn sie
sagen sie machen keine Steuer und zwei
Stunden vorher wurden die Steuern
drastisch erhöht dann ist es ein
spannendes Spiel ich freue mich auf die
nächsten Beratungen und danke herzlich
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Sebastian Brehm war das hier in der
Debatte um den Energie Soli von der
Unionsfraktion mit leicht zu fisantem
Unterton wir haben jetzt als letzte
Rednerin in diesem debattenpunkt Nadine
hesselhaus SPD Sprecherin für
Verbraucherpolitik Mitglied im
Finanzausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen
und Kollegen kommen wir jetzt zum Ende
der Debatte nochmal zum Inhalt des
Antrags und da ist es tatsächlich
bemerkenswert dass sie sich bei dem
Jahresgutachten auf das sich dieser
Antrag ja bezieht das
Sachverständigenrats sogar um ein
einstimmiges
wirtschaftswissenschaftliches Plädoyer
für eine solidarische Krisenbewältigung
handelt der Ruf nach einer stärkeren
Berücksichtigung der verteilungswirkung
auf unsere und mittlere Einkommen kommt
also auch von jenen Sachverständigen die
grundsätzlich arbeitgeberner
argumentieren und das ist doch wirklich
spannend
Tatsache ist die hohen Energiepreise
schmälern die Kaufkraft und senken den
Konsum der Privathaushalte die
Verteilungseffekte durch die
Preissteigerungen sind deutlich
Haushalte mit niedrigem Einkommen sind
am stärksten belastet weil sie weniger
zur Verfügung haben und deshalb ihr Geld
häufig vollständig ausgeben müssen die
Ampel hat hierauf reagiert und ca 200
Milliarden Euro für Entlastungen zur
Verfügung gestellt in den vergangenen
Wochen haben wir auch darüber diskutiert
wie zielgenau diese Entlastungsmaßnahmen
sind und überhaupt sein können die
Wirtschaftsweisen dringen darauf sich
nur auf unsere und mittlere Einkommen zu
konzentrieren denn das Ziel muss ihnen
zur Folge sein möglichst nur diejenigen
Haushalte zu entlasten die die hohen
Energiepreise nicht verkraften können
als SPD sehen wir uns durch diese
Aussagen stark in unserer Ausrichtung
bestätigt
denn das Gutachten sagt auch dass sich
eine zielgenaue Unterstützung niedriger
Einkommen und das ist jetzt wichtig
inflationsmindernd auswirkt eine neue
Erkenntnis für all diejenigen die auch
in Bezug auf den Mindestlohn gerne von
lohnpreisspiralen sprechen während sie
für Steuersenkungen plädieren die
insbesondere besser verdienenden zugute
kommen
jetzt gibt es allerdings folgende
Schwierigkeit unser derzeitiges System
lässt leider keine direkte Zuwendung an
diese bestimmte Personengruppe zu und
das ist ihnen allen auch bekannt deshalb
haben auch die lautesten Kritiker unter
Ihnen hierzu noch keine Alternative
aufzeigen können es gibt sie nämlich
bisher nicht und genau daran arbeiten
wir wir haben heute mit dem
Jahressteuergesetz eine Rechtsgrundlage
geschaffen um Direktzahlungen auf das
Bankkonto zu ermöglichen weil wir weg
wollen von zu viel Komplexität
und ja
wir wollen die Menschen entlasten die
das wirklich brauchen wir wollen
zukünftig einkommensabhängige Zahlungen
ermöglichen damit sie zielgenau wirken
und das wollen wir unbürokratisch und
kosteneffizient ausgestalten
meine Damen und Herren in der
Energiekrise fallen hohe zusätzliche
Ausgaben an die refinanziert werden
müssen und finanzieller Spielraum ist
notwendig wenn man gestalten möchte wir
wollen in eine soziale und ökologische
Zukunft investieren mit Mut zur
Veränderung zur Finanzierung der
erhöhten Ausgaben in der Krise schlägt
der Sachverständigenrat eine befristete
Erhöhung des Spitzensteuersatzes oder
eben die Einführung eines Energie
Solidarität
Solidaritätszuschlags für
Besserverdienende vor dies würde auch
dazu beitragen die Zielgenauigkeit des
Gesamtpakets zu erhöhen denn
Entlastungen im Energiebereich für
diejenigen die es eigentlich gar nicht
brauchen würden so wieder ausgeglichen
gleichzeitig wäre dies ein Signal dass
die Energiekrise solidarisch bewältigt
werden muss
der Antrag der Linken greift sich jedoch
mit dem energie-soli lediglich einen
einzelnen Vorschlag aus dem
Jahresgutachten des Sachverständigenrats
heraus ich finde im Gutachten stehen
noch mehr viele wichtige Punkte über die
es sich lohnt zu diskutieren die
Bundesregierung wird sich im Rahmen des
jahreswirtschaftsberichts zum Gutachten
äußern und ich freue mich auf die
Debatte hierzu vielen Dank
[Applaus]
vielen Dank ja tatsächlich die ist der
Schlusspunkt in der Debatte und den
Antrag der Linksfraktion rund um einen
energiesoli für spitzenverdienende ist
muss jetzt noch abgestimmt werden
darüber inwieweit jetzt dieser Antrag an
Ausschüsse überleben gewesen wird wir
hören jetzt mal der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin aidanösus zu
dass sie das vollzieht das sind alle
übrigen Fraktion Enthaltung keine dann
ist der Antrag abgelehnt ich rufe auf
die Tagesordnungspunkte 36A und 36b also
mit der Ablehnung des
antragstellungsfraktion auch keine
Befassung in den Ausschüssen